Congratulations.
You've completed lesson two.
[SOUND] That was a lot of concepts.
>> Piece by piece, you're learning
about all the components involved in
retrieving data from the Internet and
displaying it in an app.
>> Yeah.
We covered how to create and
configure an HTTP request,
as well as how to send a request
using the HTTP URL connection class.
>> Then, we learned how to receive and
parse the response.
Remember that the response
comes as a stream of data and
we use a buffered reader
to convert the input stream
into a string while learning
about the string builder class.
>> Totally.
There are a lot of tough
concepts in this lesson, so
be proud of yourself for
persisting through it.
>> Hey Chris, what's the best
way to really learn something?
>> What's that?
>> Is to teach somebody else.
>> Yeah, great idea.
So why don't you find a friend or
a family member and
explain what you learn in this lesson.
You can use a networking diagram
to help you teach concepts.
>> Then, let us know how
the conversation went by sharing your
experience in the discussion forum.
Good luck, you're going to do great.
>> Awesome work
finishing up this lesson.
Now, it's always good
to reflect a little bit about
the things that you've learned.
So I want you to go ahead and explain
what you've learned about networking
this lesson to a friend or
a family member.
And feel free to use the diagrams
linked below if they're helpful.
More than anything,
it'd be great if you could share your
experience in the discussion forum.
So feel free to do that,
and check this box here.